enquête sur le meurtre du petit grégory
près d'epinal avec l'inculpation
aujourd'hui d'un cousin du père de la
victime bernard laroche un reportage de
fr3 nancy de bernard laroche
depuis 48 heures les gendarmes avaient
acquis la certitude que l'umq aboutir
rapidement et qui ne leur manquait
désormais qu'une petite pièce du puzzle
pour comprendre et dénouer une affaire
qui secoue depuis trois semaines les
pensions vologne et des petites vallées
vosgiennes environnantes
cette pièce les enquêteurs allaient l'a
trouvé en interrogeant ce matin muriel
une jeune fille de 15 ans elle est la
belle-soeur de bernard laroche le témoin
numéro a mis en garde à vue avec sa
femme mercredi dernier avant d'être
relâché le lendemain
muriel avait donné un alibi le jour du
crime pour la roche un alibi qui
devaient se révéler faux ce matin
pendant deux ans et demi jean michel
lambert le juge d'instruction a
reconstitué avec muriel le trajet
supposé de l'assassin de grégory et à
l'issue de la reconstitution le juge
déclaré je suis optimiste
on brûle à la gendarmerie de bruz hier
il est alors 12 heures et tout va
s'accélérer
le juge d'instruction et les gendarmes
prennent la direction de grand-champ
vologne et vont arrêter bernard laroche
sur son lieu de travail aux
établissements en selle la roche on
ressentira les menottes aux poignets
en fait on allait la pauvre plus tard et
de bonne source muriel aurait reconnu
s'être trouvé dans la voiture de la
roche avec son fils sébastien
tous les trois sur et aller chercher
grégory pour se rendre derrière la
caserne des pompiers de doses sahel
bernard laroche se répartit quelques
instants avec grégory il est revenu seul
pendant plus de trois heures il sera
interrogé à la gendarmerie d'epinal
assiégé par les journalistes à 15 heures
bernard laroche quittera la gendarmerie
pour le bureau du juge
l'entretien durera 30 minutes il en
ressentira inculpé d'assassinât qu'est
ce qui vous a permis un témoignage
capital est en partie un rapport
d'expertisé et même des résultats
partiels ce témoignage je suis de muriel
exacte et qu'elle vous a dit exactement
à ça je n'ai pas le droit de vous le
dire le secret d'instruction et muriel a
accompagné la roche sur les lieux du
crime
elle a invité dans la voiture oui et
sébastien son fils aussi c'est lui qui a
servi d'appât
pas vraiment pas vraiment pas vraiment
dur c est ce qu invité leurs voitures
est-ce que vous allez procéder à
d'autres inculpations dans l'état actuel
du dossier je l'ignorent totalement
reste que bernard laroche a nié tout au
long des interrogatoires friante aux
journalistes un énigmatique pour nous
nos familles dans le coup et si les
enquêteurs sont ce sens persuadé de
tenir l'assassin de grégory reste
maintenant à comprendre les mobiles du
crime
revenons-en aux affaires françaises est
d'abord à ce tragique fait divers qui
depuis trois semaines traumatise toute
une région et révèle peu à peu une saga
familiale de plus en plus noir
il reste bien des mystères bien des
silences mais depuis l'inculpation hier
du cousin du père du petit grégory
les réactions de ses proches paraissent
de plus en plus accablantes sur place
isabelle bechler c'est sur la foi d'un
analyste graphologique et du témoignage
de sa belle-soeur que bernard laroche a
été inculpé d'assassinât mais toute
cette agitation semble le laisser de
marbre comme s'il s'agissait de
l'histoire d'un autre il affirmé son
innocence mais presque sans conviction
ni ans en bloc les jalousies qu'on lui
prête tels que son penchant passé pour
tous civils
tel que la douleur d'avoir un enfant une
grosse centrale alors que bruges aurait
été intelligent
la riante sa femme ne croit pas à la
fugue d'ailleurs delà du même âge comme
j'avais eu comme il est avec mon fils
une laie mille le chéri de non non non
c'est pas vrai qu'il y ait même pas
capable de tuer à lapins lorsque je ne
crois pas qu'il soit capable de faire du
mal comme ça
ou qu'est ce que vous pensez du
témoignage de muriel parce que c'est
capital quand même
comme je viens de le dire je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé je ne
sais pas ce qui se passe pour eux qui me
l'a arrêté comme ça je ne sais pas mais
vous croyez que muriel l'a inventé j'en
crois rien du tout j'attends j'attends
la suite de leur enquête y attend elle
était dans sa voiture ce jour là ils
sont ils sont allés à la vologne
ils sont en euros l'once à cette toutes
des choses qui sont dites que c'est
totalement faux au cap solvants faux et
c'est peut-être un autre bernard qu'on a
découvert la n'a pas de visage sports et
bernard laroche un double visage contre
m tudieu qui cacherait ta justice et
familiale est aussi l'hypothèse que
retient jacky vimond qui fut élevée avec
lui si c'est vraiment lui que fait le
coup c'est docteur jekyll mr et te dire
que de façade il est bien mais
l'intérieur il est complètement pourri
les ombres va soupçonner dans un
soupçonne à mon compte personnel
l'enquète se poursuite avec ce soir une
nouvelle audition du témoin capital
muriel qui affirme qu'elle était dans la
voiture de bernard laroche au moment de
l'enlèvement du petit greg mentale
dramatique et sordide affaire de
l'assassinât du petit grégory vient de
connaître son premier dénouement avec
l'inculpation d'un cousin de la victime
déjà suspecté la semaine dernière mais
cette fois-ci inculpé d'assassinât car
sont malades
son alibi pour le jour et l'heure du
crime s'est écroulé l'inculper pour sa
part continue de crier son innocence en
tout cas sur place l'émotion est grande
on le devine aisément le reportage notre
envoyé spécial isabelle belle façon
personne dans la famille n'est capable
de faire un truc comme ça c'est pas
possible
le corbeau c'est pas sympa mais ni moi
ni ma femme si on a la conscience
tranquille
donc c'est ça qui nous a sauvés voilà ce
qu'il dit de quatre jours avant la
culture hier 12h30 quand les gendarmes
arrivent tôt filature en selle bernard
laroche est à son poste de travail
il se croit toujours protégé par la
libye de muriel sa belle soeur de 15 ans
qui a affirmé qu'elle l'avait vu à plus
de 15 km du lieu du crime
le 16 octobre dernier mais hier matin
muriel a parlé aux gendarmes et aux
juges
elle a avoué qu'elle avait eu peur et la
faisait ses mots et c'est finalement
libérer du fardeau qu'elle portait
depuis 20 jours
c'est le témoignage qu'attendaient les
enquêteurs pour pouvoir interpeller
bernard laroche pour de bon car il
savait bien qu'il ne fallait pas espérer
d'aveux le cousin de jean marie villemin
était dure à l'interrogatoire
jamais il n'avait admis la moindre
jalousie le moindre dépit il n'avait
donné prise à aucune thèse de mobiles
hier à la gendarmerie d'epinal il
continuait de nier
15h averti par la rumeur publique les
curieux guettait déjà le meurtrier
présumé
sous le préau du palais de justice le
juge lambert lui attendait bernard
laroche pour lui signifier son
inculpation
nous devions d'apprendre que la jeune
fille qui servait d'alibi à la roche
l'avait accompagné tout le temps du
crime
uriel à accompagner bernard laroche sur
les lieux du crime
[Musique]
habiter dans la voiture si sébastien son
fils aussi c'est lui qui a servi d'appât
pour vraiment vraiment pas vraiment
mieux c est ce que vivent et ils dans la
voiture est ce que vous allez procéder à
d'autres occupations
dans l'état actuel du dossier je
l'ignorent totalement vous n'avez pas
l'intention d'inculper muriel en
ampoules pour l'instant
c'est totalement exclu totalement hors
de cause
le corbeau est l'assassin le rigorisme
va donc via le même homme dans la
famille on est consterné jacky villemin
qui a été élevé avec la roche ne
comprends pas pour l'instant on peut
toujours pas l'expliquer je pense on
attend même une explication des
gendarmes pour pouvoir savoir le fait un
monde tout seul parce que
psychologiquement vous ne savez pas ce
qui a pu ce qui a pu l'amener la cil à
cil a tué grégory et et 6 il a pu
devenir fou si c'est vraiment lui que
fait le coup c'est docteur jekyll mr et
c'est à dire que de façade il est bien
mais l'intérieur j'ai complètement
pourri mais on veut pas me soupçonner
dans insoupçonnable mon compte personnel
l'instruction de la sphère du meurtre du
petit grégory se poursuit à epinal hier
juge d'instruction a reçu la mère de
l'enfant assassiné une audition qui pose
bien des questions
pascal guimier 36 jours après la mort du
petit grégory l'enquète semble piétiner
hier plusieurs témoins entendus par le
juge d'abord christine et jean marie
villemin les parents de la victime
ensuite michel villemin l'oncle de
l'enfant c'est d'après le témoignage de
christine et de michel que les gendarmes
ont pu établir la chronologie exacte des
événements et ceci dès le début de la
faire tout ce serait donc passé entre 17
heures et 17 heures 26 le 16 octobre
dernier à 17 heures selon sa mère
l'enfant jouait devant la maison à 17h26
l'oncle recevait un appel du corbeau
revendiquant le crime
les gendarmes continuent de vérifier
l'emploi du temps des villemin et de
leurs proches pour ne rien laisser au
hasard
quatre jeunes femmes ont également été
entendu hier par le juge trois d'entre
elles seraient des collègues de travail
de christine villemin
elle affirme l'avoir vu poster une
lettre le jour même du crime alors même
où le corbeau envoyée sa dernière lettre
la mère de l'enfant elle après trois des
positions contradictoires affirmant que
c'était la veille après le meurtre de
bernard laroche l'homme qu'on avait
suspecté d'être l'assassin du petit
grégory et qui hier a été tué d'un coup
de fusil par le père de l'enfant
christine villemin la mère a été placée
aujourd'hui à garde en garde à vue et la
police interroge le juge lambert chargé
de l'instruction est rentré de vacances
précipitamment et puis nouveau
rebondissement on met maintenant en
cause un capitaine de la gendarmerie
marie ange laroche l'accusent d'avoir
provoqué le meurtre de son mari
les gendarmes étaient des saisies de la
sphère pas pour ça que le capitaine
tasma n'a pas été poussé jean marie
plusieurs fois alors là aussi lui dit
que c'était lui
tu l as roi c'était la gauche si fort
mais comment vous expliquer le geste de
jean marie gillain foutu de sang-froid
votre mari
il a été poussé ou du procès cement et
finit sa fin la question se pose à notre
avis du rôle de christine villemin dans
la préparation d'assassinât de bernard
laroche
elle n'a pas hésité à mettre en outre en
cause personnellement le capitaine cesma
qui selon elle aurait joué le rôle de
directeur de conscience de jean marie
villemin dans ses projets criminels
épinal dans la sphère du petit grégory
on s'enfonce chaque jour un peu plus
dans le drame
aujourd'hui le juge lambert a refusé la
mise en liberté provisoire de christine
villemin réclamée par son avocat et son
mari jean marie villemin
incarcéré à la prison de nancy a lui
aussi comme son épouse engagée jusqu'à
la fin dit-il
une grève de la faim sur place nous
envoyés spéciaux marcel trillât thierry
mais ni christine villemin toujours en
grève de la faim ne quittera pas le
quartier des femmes de la prison de metz
queuleu où elle est incarcérée depuis le
vendredi dernier
ce matin à epinal tandis que la caravane
du tour de france se préparait pour une
nouvelle étape presque sous ses fenêtres
le juge lambert recevait m au garrot
venu lui renouveler sa demande de mise
en liberté provisoire de christine
villemin
sans illusion comment monsieur juge
d'instruction se déjugera deux jours
d'intervalle jeu trois jours
j'espère qu'à n'ont lieu que la mise en
liberté de christine ça va soit
ultérieurement un non lieu en faveur de
christine et enfin j'espère que les
preuves seront réunies contre l'assassin
et qu'il n'ya plus de questions à ce
sujet
midi le juge lambert tout secret que
jamais quitte le palais de justice en
apprendra bientôt pourtant qu'il est
resté inflexible
il ya que le procureur le comte lui ai
suggéré à nouveau de libérer christine
villemin et de la placer sous contrôle
judiciaire
il décide lui le maintien en détention
en début d'après midi nouveau
rebondissement du fond de sa cellule de
la prison charles iii de nancy jean
marie villemin entame à son tour une
grève de la faim entre le juge et les
villemin l'épreuve de force est
maintenant clairement engagée la
décision finale appartient à la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de nancy
qui a 30 jours pour statuer
compte tenu de l'état de santé précaire
de testing in main enceinte de cinq mois
et demi et qui a déjà perdu l'un des
jumeaux qu'elle portait cette décision
pourrait bien contredire celle du juge
lambert les hommes du commissaire
andrieu de la police judiciaire de nancy
de leur côté ont été chargés d'une
nouvelle commission rogatoire leur
permettra de bétonner comme on dit leur
dossier un dossier qu'ils jugent solides
mais qui comporte encore de nombreuses
zones d'ombré un dossier qui accable
christine villemin
mais sans aveux ni preuves formelles et
surtout qui laisse sans réponse la
principale question pourquoi j'en ai
décisif demain pour christine villemin
inculpée de l'assassinât de son fils est
emprisonné à metz la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de nancy
examinera la demande de mise en liberté
provisoire déposée par la mère de
grégory est rejetée par le juge lambert
les magistrats de nancy se pencheront
avec beaucoup d'attention sur l'emploi
du temps de christine villemin
alors du meurtre le 16 octobre 80 cas
tout c'est peut-être joué en moins de 20
minutes c'est ce que pense le juge
lambert mais l'avocat de christine
villemin rejette soupçon impossible
dit-il de croire que la mère de grégory
a pu faire disparaître son enfant en un
laps de temps aussi court
ces 20 minutes sont donc déterminante
marcel trillât et thierry mais n'y ont
tenté de les reconstituer
christine villemin quitte son travail au
centre de l'étrange
il est 16 heures 56 le 16 octobre 1984
dans quelques minutes son fils grégory
mourir les camarades de travail affirme
l'avoir vu poster une lettre à l'heure
où le corbeau expédié la sienne
annonçant l'assassinât de l'enfant
elle prétend être allé directement
vendre son fils chez la nourrice avant
de remonter chez elle et dernier à
l'avoir vue monsieur colin et madame
quand didier
ils bavardent 6,6 en haut du village une
voiture passe de tenir montait dans sa
voiture
pour des parties madame d'une main au
monde
mais là je ne peux pas dire si son petit
garçon était avec elle c'est quand je
suis rentré à ma cuisine il était 5
heures vous pensez tout de suite après
2-3 min et vous avez regardé l'heure oui
parce que j'allais faire cinquante
mètres plus haut un croisement pour
christine villemin aucun doute elle a
pris à droite vers chez elle peu après
17 heures elle s'enferme pour repasser
l'enfant joue dans la cour la voiture
est dans le garage sans porte à droite
de la maison
pourtant quelques minutes plus tard
monsieur colin longe la villa sans
remarquer ni l'enfant ni la voiture
alors christine villemin a tellement
tille en haut du village at elle tourné
à gauche vers de celle où grégory est
mort nous avons chronométré à plusieurs
reprises le trajet les planches de celle
sur cette route étroite et tortueuse où
personne ne l'a aperçu ce jour-là une
route souvent encombrée par les
tracteurs et les troupeaux au bout de la
route le village de dos elle que
christine aurait traversé presque de
part en part
à l'heure de sortie d'une usine de 250
ouvriers près de l'église
elle aurait ligoter l'enfant puis
l'aurait jetée dans la vologne
derrière le bâtiment des sapeurs
pompiers d'après les simulations faites
à l'aide de mannequins
c'est ici en effet que l'enfant à lui
être noyé pour que son corps ait pu
dériver jusqu'au barrage en contrebas où
ans l'a repêché il faisait beau ce jour
là les habitants de naucelle profiter
des derniers rayons de soleil d'octobre
personne n'a vu l'horrible scène en
plein jour en plein village
compte tenu du temps nécessaire pour
ligoter l'enfant trois minutes d'après
les enquêteurs il aurait fallu en tout
plus de 19 minutes à christine villemin
pour faire l'aller-retour à un train
d'enfer sans hésitation ni incident de
parcours et tout cela avec une petite
voiture en très mauvais état
elle a été vue pour la dernière fois on
s'en souvient près de cet embranchement
environ deux minutes avant 17 heures 19
minutes plus tard le temps minimum du
trajet à 17h17 madame claudon et son
mari viennent chercher leurs troupeaux
juste au dessous de la maison des villes
mhz tandis que monsieur claude on barre
la route avec sa voiture
madame claude au monde peut placer une
barrière devant chez les villemin où
elle ne voit personne
puis elle redescend faire sortir les
vaches de son prêt et les pousser vers
la route vers 17h20 elle passe pour la
seconde fois devant la maison d wilm et
puis j'ai reparti avec le trophée alors
elle m'a demandé si j'avais vu grégory
j'ai dit non il est capable - peu près
parce que j'étais chez nous j'ai dit à
mon mari
il est sain que records vous avez pas
été chercher les marches parce que
j'étais à retordre d'habitude je viens
te jure à sac
christine villemin ne pouvait pas
prévoir le retard de madame claude haut
au retour de dos elle elle risquait de
se trouver nez à nez avec elle et elle
le savait dans l'hypothèse où elle est
coupable et seul coupable
elle a bénéficié pour parcourir le
trajet dans les temps et commettre son
crime sans être vue d'une chance
diabolique
elle a fait preuve d'une détermination
et d'un sang froid digne d'une
criminelle d'exception une thèse qui
aurait bien besoin de preuves décisives
ou d'aveux pour devenir irréfutables et
pour dissiper vraiment le mystère de la
mort du petit grégory
la sphère grégory suite avec les
confrontations qui ont eu lieu hier à
epinal aujourd'hui le juge lambert va
continuer ses auditions hier les six
membres de la famille villemin ont passé
plusieurs heures dans le cabinet du juge
et il ne semble pas qu'un nouvel élément
déterminant soit sorti de cette
confrontation un climat tendu
martèle-t-il bousculade hier soir à la
sortie du tribunal d'epinal
[Musique]
les gendarmes qui espoirs de jean marie
villemin ont lancé carrément leur
fourgon en marche arrière dans la foule
des journalistes manière un peu
expéditive peut-être de répondre aux
critiques suscitées par les errements de
leur enquête
[Musique]
pendant huit heures dans le bureau du
juge lambert on avait tenté une fois de
plus de percer le mystère du ou des
corbeau qui harcelait pendant plus de
deux ans christine et jean marie
villemin
mais aussi les parents et les frère de
jean-marie aujourd'hui partie civile
on a essuyé les uns après les autres
toutes une série de toute une série de
faits d'appels notamment qui concerne et
danseurs
vous ne vendrez qui est qui avait été au
centre d'un futur aujourd'hui c'est le
corps pour présenter tous aussi entendu
oui oui les tous
feria vraiment un pas qui a été franchi
dans son siège très significative une
absence dont on parle beaucoup christine
villemin reparti hier matin sans avoir
rencontré ses beaux parents
elle était presque toujours seul car
leur flore beau appeler ce qui conforte
la thèse de ses accusateurs mais comment
prouver quoi que ce soit aujourd'hui
avec tout ce temps perdu
des investigations tordu c'est pas de
retard mais pour faire ce qui n'a pas
aidé c'est sûr quand on traite en tout
cas c'est l'été disons que ça a été fait
immédiatement
on n'en serait pas là une soirée
éprouvante mais qui ne semble pas pour
autant avoir entamé l'assurance des
avocats de la défense français nous
attendons avec confiance une décision de
non lieu en faveur de christine et il
est elle toujours la mal aimée de la
famille disons pas comme ça je vois le
dossier voilà celui qui s'en va le
dernier discrètement dans la nuit le
juge lambert plus seul que jamais la
reconstitution du meurtre du petit
grégory a eu lieu à lépanges sur vologne
elle devait permettre de vérifier
l'emploi du temps de la mère du petit
garçon qui est au centre du débat à
propos de sa culpabilité sur place notre
envoyé spécial
marcel trillât coupable ou innocente
ce soir encore très sylvie llm conserve
son secret en attendait beaucoup
pourtant dollar en constitution de ce
matin destinée à préciser les faits et
gestes de la mère de grégory le 16
octobre 1984
entre 17h et 17h30 en fait deux thèses
inconciliables se sont opposés à nouveau
sous le regard du juge lambert la
première se fonde sur le témoignage de
bernard colas il est l'un des derniers à
avoir vu christine villemin dans sa
voiture avant la disparition de l'enfant
vers 17 heures parce qu'il est revenu de
sa promenade quotidienne au moment où
christine partait à la recherche de son
fils il était d'après le minutage
effectué ce matin
17h33 pour madame claude ont au
contraire il était environ 17 heures 20
elle remontait avec ses vaches devant la
maison des villes mme deux affirmations
fragile comme tous les témoignages
humains une contradiction pourtant
capital pour christine villemin
dans le premier cas elle ne dispose pas
du temps matériel nécessaire pour
commettre le crime qui lui est reproché
dans le second cas sa culpabilité
devient possible
les vérifications d'aujourd'hui n'auront
pas suffi pour trancher
bonsoir le juge d'instruction jean
michel lambert conformément à
l'inculpation prononcée en juillet 85
entre christine villemin persiste et
signe il persiste dans sa conviction de
la culpabilité de christine villemin
pour le juge il ya suffisamment de
charges pour renvoyer la mère du petit
grégory devant les jurés d'une cour
d'assises il a donc signé une ordonnance
de renvoi devant la chambre d'accusation
de la cour d'appel de nancy
quels sont les éléments du dossier du
juge lambert explications avec roland
sicard
c'est contre l'avis du parquet d'epinal
et de la chancellerie que le juge
lambert inculpé christine villemin
d'homicide en juillet 1985 pour le juge
deux éléments de preuve principaux le
premier une incertitude de 15 minutes
dont une opa du temps de christine
villemin au moment du crime à l'appui le
témoignage d'un voisin
la voiture de la jeune femme n'était pas
dans son garage le jour du meurtre
pour le juge christine villemin pouvait
donc se trouver au bord de la vologne
quand son fils a été assassiné second
élément de preuve la cordelette que les
policiers de nancy découvre chez les
villemin de laboratoire arrive à la même
conclusion
c'est la même cordelette qui a servi
attaché les pieds et les mains du petit
grégory
un faisceau de présomptions qui conduit
le juge lambert à faire incarcérer
christine villemin la prison de metz en
juillet 85 une incarcération qui ne
durera que douze jours
la chambre d'accusation de nancy ordonne
la mise en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire de la jeune femme
le 16 juillet 1985 de son côté christine
villemin a toujours nié
selon elle elle n'avait pas le temps
matériel de tuer son fils dont les
quelques minutes où les enquêteurs
perdent sa trace
des enquêteurs qui ne trouveront
d'ailleurs aucun mobile qui pourrait
accuser christine villemin
aujourd'hui le juge lambert a transmis
son dossier la chambre d'accusation de
nancy c'est elle qui devra décider du
non lieu ou de la mise en accusation
devant la cour d'assises jean michel
lambert
c'est bien la première fois que je vais
procéder à l'interrogatoire d'un juge
d'instruction
j'ai vu dans france soir quand 10
j'emmerde avoir le procureur qui voit là
et je dois vous avouer que je préfère
vous interviewez que l'interroger plutôt
que l' inverse parce que ça évidemment
ce serait pas bon signe pour moi si
c'est l inverse
alors avez vous avez vous remarqué que
le verbe commettre s'emploie à la fois
pour un crime et pour un livre
d'ailleurs mari m'a alors et avez vous
l'impression d'avoir commis un livre ou
pas d'avoir écrit alliot marie a fait
d'avoir commis et alors pourquoi
pourquoi avez vous écrit un livre comme
celui ci est ce que parce que vous êtes
vous devenu vous même une vedette de la
sphère villemin normandie si vous
n'aviez pas été le juge d'instruction de
l'affairé villemin est donc devenu à
cause de cette affaire célèbre auriez
vous pensé écrire l'histoire la vie
quotidienne d'un juge d'instruction
sincèrement je pense que oui mais il est
certain que l'impact n'aurait pas été le
même parce que l'on juge de province
aurait pas eu la chance d'être connu oui
c'est à dire que beaucoup de magistrats
attendent la retraite pour recueillir
leurs souvenirs
voilà c'est pour le mans ce que vous
auriez fait et peut-être auriez-vous eu
du mal à trouver un éditeur si vous
n'aviez pas eu n'était pas devenu
célèbre par la ferme il m'a assez sage
convient tout à fait oui tout à fait bon
alors la sphère ville m'a d'ailleurs
n'occupe qu'une part très modeste donne
dans le livre ah oui parce que je suis
donc lié par le secret de fonction dont
je ne peux rien dire sur le fond nous du
dossier et je n'aborde que les aspects
que je peux donc évoqué à savoir bon et
les lettres anonymes reçues
puis l'analyse de la sphère dans les
rapports avec les médias
bon alors là ferdinand en apparence bien
thaler mais vous raconter beaucoup
d'autres affaires qu'ils sont passés
pendant votre commande est votre
ministère demandez votre
non bon wagon pendant vos activités qui
ont commencé quand d'un dans les mi
février 1980 81 alors on vous dit au
départ vous allez voir ce les vosges
c'est un département et se passe pas
grand chose
et puis quand on voit tout ce que vous
racontez que de crime que de vivre que
de sens que de haine mais c'est
absolument effrayant c'est la même chose
comme ça dans tous les os ou est tombé
fait débat c'est partout pareil
absolument absolument tous les juges
d'instruction les 550 collègues environ
juge d'instruction de france ont chacun
dans leurs cabinets d affaires du même
ordre
mais c'est absolument effrayant alors
vous vous raconter que vous avez eu une
enfance très protégé assez douillette et
tout d'un coup vous passer de cette
enfance douillette à un monde de 200 de
haine avec même des autopsies auquel
vous assistez et chivu le lève le coeur
est ce que je me disais au fond en
lisant votre i je me disais ce qu' il
n'aurait pas mieux valu que vous ayez eu
une enfance plus un peu plus difficile
un peu plus chahutées parce que le
contraste aurait peut-être été moins
saisissant peut-être mais disons qu'il y
à des événements comme ceux ci forme et
agréable auquel nom ne finit jamais par
s'y habituer mais bon ça fait partie du
travail mais par exemple les les
autopsies auxquels vous devez assister
tout à fait tout à fait un jeu j'évoque
cette odeur de la mort qui est quelque
chose d'absolument abominable et qui
imprègne après les vêtements et on vous
avait dit à l'école d'un jour a menacé
hier d'ailleurs à l'école nous avons
tous assisté à au moins une autopsie
mais ça fait partie du travail est alors
vous raconter d'ailleurs je le dis avec
beaucoup de détails et les autopsies et
les viols
1up pas que ça pas que ça et n'ont même
pas voulu raconter avec beaucoup de
détails je vous demander pourquoi on n'y
voyait aucun de vos intentions de noms
demeurent non qu'il m'a dit 'ce abord
m'organise bien alors laisse que j'ai
peut-être commis un livre mais ce n'est
pas comme est bon est ce que
et est ce que là la sphère villemin bon
qui vous a rendu célèbres vous a rendu
semelle a rendu tous les gens au célèbre
de tous les gens qui s'occupent l
affaire villemin sont devenus des gens
célèbres
évidemment les suspects le les les
journalistes le juge d'instruction
certains policiers etc
les avocats est-ce que vous pensez que
ça n'est pas quand même quelque chose de
condamnable que tout le monde soit
devenue une des stars grâce à cette
affaire abominable et je rappelle au
départ c'est quand même le meurtre d'un
enfant de carrément so lu ment
absolument ça c'est un élément qu'il ne
faut pas perdre de vue s condamnable
c'est difficile à dire c'est nous avons
tous été confrontés à ce problème est
justement nous sommes tous devenus entre
guillemets des des stars le mot est
vraiment à mettre entre guillemets
maintenant nous mais bien l'impression
que l' affaire villemin dans votre vie
professionnelle
c'est une chance ou c'est une malchance
non pour sûr on ne peut pas employer le
mot chance sans ne peut pas employer de
nos chances ne pouvait pas en prix non
plus le mot malchance non je crois que
l'on peut pas raisonner en termes sont
là dessus de chance ou de malchance
c'est un coup du sort un coup du sort du
destin vous dites ces six onze mois plus
tard g6 trail autopsie d'un autre enfant
âgé de 4 ans et demi grégory victime
d'un assassinat que seul pouvait
expliquer une forme de folie
quel qu'en fût l'auteur un crime qui ne
regardaient peut-être pas la justice des
hommes
j'étais très surpris que vous qui était
censé vous occupez la justice des hommes
tout d'un coup vous avez fière de vous
décharger sur dieu ou le ciel de ces
normes non sur une forme de folie oui
même quand vous dis un crime qui ne
regardent peut-être pas la justice des
hommes tous les crimes regarda justin
oui oui c'est vous voulez ça m'allait
vous voulez non non mais là vous avez
tout à fait raison tout à fait raison
mais ceci dit effectivement il ya
peut-être des les nuances introduire et
peut-être qu'effectivement ce crime ne
regarde pas la justice des hommes
mais comment comme mais c'est étonnant
quand même la bouche d'un juge
d'instruction c'est à cette phrase dire
quoi tout ça fond non ça je ne peux pas
en dire plus
bon comment expliquez-vous la
extraordinaire médiatisation de ceux de
l' affaire villemin je crois pour une
raison bien simple j'ai souvent lu que
des germanistes écrire qu'au départ
c'était un banal fait divers
or en fait non c'est un fait divers qui
n'a jamais été banane en raison d'une
composante essentielle dans qu'au départ
de la faire quitter le l'existence la
présence d'un corbeau parce que ce que
l'on appelait entre guillemets le
corbeau et je crois d affaire de corbeau
bon il n'y en avait déjà eu dans le
l'histoire judiciaire française
mais tout ce contexte avec donc c'est
assassinats d'enfants qui avaient donc
été prémédité revendiquer juste avant
revendiquer juste après je crois c'est
ce qui a transformé donc entre
guillemets un banal fait divers qui peut
être un assassinat l'enfant ont fait
divers extraordinaire c'est vrai que
tout le monde a concouru à la la
médiatisation de ce fait divers de ce
crime atroce par exemple les avocats me
n'ai pas beaucoup les avocats ça au nom
éponyme
comment d'abord vous n'aimez pas les
avocats parisiens qui descendent comme
des stars kari bhl la veille d'une
affaire et qui se font payer grassement
et qui regardent à peine le dossier
avant d'aller plaider a suffi je
pourrais vous retrouvez l'info j'aime
mettre au défi moins sûr je vais le
retrouver
le et vous dites aussi par exemple que
la presse la presse courent de grands
risques d'être utilisés par des avocats
peut se retrouver pour assurer le relais
de la défense leurs clients clim en
clamant son innocence immense dans
l'avenir oui donc les avocats sont quand
même et perd les journalistes vivent il
est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas le beau rôle
non plus ce qui est normal et je dis à
tous les accabler un peu encore pour
nous allons maintenant pas quand même
miser
je les ai gratté in sur les écrans oui
et puis vous avez craqué et devantures
oui vous avez cédé vous avez cédé vous
aussi au prestige de la notoriété
vous savez c'est plus compliqué ce n'est
pas en termes de de notoriété que l'on
peut parler c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que cela quand vous êtes seul pendant
des mois dans une affaire comme ça et
que l'on vous fait miroiter monts un
article plaisant le fêter on cède on sen
alors j'y retrouvais le passage oui
à l'issue de son interrogatoire de
première comparution françois j avais
choisi une avocate du bureau d'epinal
pour assurer sa défense devant la
session des assises il s'adjoindre les
services d'un ténor du barreau parisien
j'apprendrai que ce cher homme
commencera par demander 20 mille francs
d'honoraires qu'il arrivera epinal la
veille du grand jour qu'il découvrira
étudiera le dossier dans la nuit
françois hadji sera condamné à 4 années
d'emprisonnement même dans les affaires
de crimes passionnels j'ai juré bon
gageons que s'il avait oui d'accord
c'est alors qu'ericsson bon et nous
avons un jury populaire l'a alors
philippe labro caisse ou je me pose des
questions sur ce livre et je suis pas
seul parce que vous avez lu dans la
presse qu'un selon le magistrat qui se
pose des questions si vous voyez vos 550
collègues je monte savoir si vous auriez
dû l'écrire c'est la première question
d'une question j'aimerais bien savoir
pourquoi vous mentionnez jamais bernard
laroche
et puis la troisième question c'est que
je crois que vous
alors trop tendance à accabler les
autres alors non à la télé et en rendant
leur dawn est ce que vous avez eu raison
de l'écrire et j'ai voulu témoigner
témoigner sur ce qui est la justice
contemporaine j'aurais pu le faire en
écrivant un livre qui se serait appelée
la vie quotidienne la juge d'instruction
ces juges et peut-être à tort mais j'ai
agi suivant mon tempérament de
d'employer le jeu de dire voilà moi et
jean michel lambert entre guillemets
juge d'instruction epinal voici ce qui
m'est arrivé
voici ce qui m'arrivait avant le 16
octobre 84
voici ce qui m'est arrivé voilà comment
les choses se passent mais moi j'ai pas
été élevé dans l'idée que les juges
d'instruction devait révéler une grande
partie du secret l'organisant c'est leur
métier
mon idée de la justice il n'avait pas à
mon avis vous n'avez pas tout à fait
raison sardines à l'empa peut-être que
si la justice le célèbre la justice est
rendue au nom du peuple français
les français ne connaissent pas la
justice ils ne savent pas comment
fonctionne vivre pendant on croyait
qu'il a commis selon tahar cris a je
pense
ils ne connaissent pas le tous les rois
je ne parle pas des des jeux
qui joue siège je ne parle pas des parcs
et mais je pense que concernant
l'instruction ils en sauront un peu plus
la deuxième question l'étonnement
n'allait pas de bernard laroche pouliot
qui a été inculpé so lu ment que vous
avez exercé actionné mercredi d'une
solide et puis qui ensuite a été tu vois
là chez tu es un grand beau frère a fait
mais alors là c'est un drame d'abord je
n'en parle pas et je sais la réplique et
vous allez me dire je n'en parle pas
parce que l'affairé n'est pas jugée
alors si nico nationale appliquons va
pas là dit alain ce cas là si l'affairé
n'est pas jugée pourquoi écrire ce livre
en tout cas pour pouvoir mettre deux
chapitres sur la sphère c'est vrai qu'il
n'y ait de chapitres i centre sa
cassette et qui analyse des aspects tout
à fait annette sale affaire parce qu'ils
disent vos collègues
les avis sont semble-t-il très partagés
plutôt même hostile
je vous dire ce qui est donc vous rendez
vous avez une année sabbatique labour
prendrez votre métier de juge à la fin
de l'année où sont les miens attention
oui le 1er janvier
88 mais epinal un an paul abine un nom
ça je serais nommé l'annuaire c'est le
meilleur mais vous pensez pas alors que
toute votre vie professionnelle de juges
vous serez le petit juge celui qui a
instruit l'affairé villemin celui qui a
écrit ce livre et ses pensées 6,6 soit
réalisé certains 500 me marquera tout et
vous pensez pas d'ailleurs que ça va
changer un petit peu là la manière dont
vous allez procéder que les avocats les
inculpés ne seront pas devant vous comme
il serait devant un autre juge
d'instruction soit tout à fait et ça
n'est pas gênant l'avenir le livre mais
c'est sûr que ce sera très difficile
très difficile
et puis ça que philippe bouvard raconté
qu'un jour vous êtes venu la voir et
vous l'avez demandé
comme comment faire dûment devenir
célèbre j'ai même lu ça dans le canard
enchaîné de services domaines non alors
ça je démens totalement
il est exact que j'avais rencontré
philippe bou
à ma demande au mois de mai 1980 vous
savez monsieur la brocade et les
magistrats ont d une formation continue
et donc peuvent passer une semaine dans
un organe de presse
c'est que j'aurai plus donc c'est
l'école qui choisit j'aurais pu aller
rtl je vois qu aller au monde et l'école
m'aviez trouver un stage à france soir
donc étant à france soir j'ai tourné
dans différents services
il est exact que j'ai demandé à
rencontrer monsieur philippe bauer que
je tenais pour un très grand
professionnel et qui aimerait vous tenez
où tiens le jour
je vous accorde le tient bon en revanche
deux records le juge lambert parce que
d'ordinaire dans le récit de ce genre
d'affaires criminelles
on pleure on pleure sur l'enfant qui a
été tué ou bien on pleure sur la mer si
elle est innocent du crime d'antan la
crise et lisant ce livre tout à coup on
pleure sur le juge mais c'est un livre
qui qui fait qu'ils vraiment apitoie sur
le rôle du juge
j'étais en face c'était mouvement à la
lecture lorsqu'il faut dire que vous
ayez un petit avocat quand même ici mais
et puis j'ai joué avec plusieurs
journalistes bien ce que journaliste
j'ai pas toujours apprécié la façon dont
ils sont traités dans le livre du juge
lambert mais je crois que c'est
l'organisation de la justice française
qui est imputable car
elle est organisée de telle façon d'un
jeu de magistrats qui sort de l'école
qui a eu le cette jeunesse protégé qui
connaît rien de la vie se trouve
brusquement envoyé dans un pays où le
terroir est très fort où les gens ont
des ans démarre un peu secrète un peu
rustique qu'il ne connaît pas qu'elle
est complètement étranger et qui
brusquement se voir apporter dans son
cabinet d'instruction une affaire
tragique particulièrement tragique et là
je crois que la justice dans ces cas là
est un peu coupable de délégués autant
de pouvoir à quelqu'un qui n'a pas ni
les compétences ni la formation morale
et intellectuelle pour assumer une telle
l'état et qui n'est préparé ni à
l'horreur ni à celle absolument alors
simplement c'est vrai vous avez été
beaucoup critiqués parce que raconter
quand vous inculper christine villemin
vous pleurez avant vous dites voilà j'ai
plus aurait dû une fois qu'elle est
inculpé vous pleurez encore après et
vous dites même que cela perturbe votre
vie sexuelle
bon moi j'ai trouvé bon il ya des gens
qui se moquent de cet aveu moi pas très
franchement je trouve que c'est pour
beaucoup de courage pour avouer ce genre
de choses parce qu'effectivement c'est
on s'en moque assez facilement les
larmes la juge d'instruction
quelqu'un qui vient avec une inculpé
et puis même ces inculpations qui vient
troubler sa vie intime tout ça est un et
se prêtent à rire
moi j'ai plutôt été un peu émue l'a
plutôt que payer un assez pitoyable
parle par le rôle que tient le juge est
parée par cette mission qui finalement
je crois que la vraie question c'est de
savoir si monsieur mais où jean michel
lambert était fait pour être une
instruction alors quelle est la réponse
et il vous fait pour être juge
d'instruction moi j'ai le sentiment que
oui et eti et pensez vous pas que c'est
de la faire est arrivé trop tôt dans
votre vie professionnelle et peut-être
peut-être mais ça c'est une affaire
comme ça on en rencontre une fois tous
les 20 ou 30 ans
le juge lambert témoin vedette à la cour
d'assises de dijon le petit juge comme
on l'appelle familièrement instruit le
dossier grégory il y a quelques années
il ya neuf ans c'est lui qui avait
souvenez vous inculper bernard laroche
et christine villemin
ses explications sur les ratages
policier judiciaire était très attendue
ce matin
d'entrée de jeu il a déclaré qu'il ne
croyait pas à la piste la roche compte
rendu d'audience dominique verdeilhan
eric de l'agneau jamais un témoin n'aura
été autant attendu par la presse comme
par la justice jean michel lambert c'est
la concierge du palais qui lui montre le
chemin car la cour d'assises l'attend
depuis deux semaines mais bientôt la
tâche est trop dure et ce sont les
policiers qui vole au secours du petit
juge lorsque jean michel lambert est
arrivé à epinal en 1980 ses collègues
lui avais dit qu ici il ne se passe
jamais rien on connaît la suite
à 9h45 ce matin le juge fait son entrée
dans la salle d'audience
lorsqu'il arrive dix minutes plus tôt à
dijon le juge sait déjà ce qu'il va dire
une question posée à la cour d'assises
est ce que bernard laroche pouvait
savoir le 16 octobre 84 que christine
villemin laisserait grégory devant la
maison cette question je ne me la suis
pas causer dès le début je lave ou pour
moi la réponse est négative
il y a là une invraisemblance qui est de
nature à innocenter bernard laroche le
silence est total dans la salle jean
marie villemin accuse le coup à la barre
le juge lambert persiste et signe sa
deuxième piste et pour lui la bonne
pourtant à aucun moment le juge lambert
n'a cité le nom de christine villemin
mais tout le monde a compris des erreurs
j'en ai commises mais je ne fuis pas mes
responsabilités
lens sûr de lui le petit juge mais jean
michel lambert ne semblent pas percevoir
que les questions du président olivier
roussel ce ne sont guère flatteuse à son
encontre le président de la cour
d'assises lui rappelle ainsi ces
questions ambigu vis-à-vis de christine
villemin
les oublis de son enquête les expertises
annulé faute de procédure où les scellés
qui ont disparu le président de la cour
d'assises souligne également l'aspect
influençable du match
str à face à certains témoignages et
face aux enquêteurs devant cette mise en
cause
le petit juge jean michel lambert ne
semble avoir qu'une seule réponse
neuf ans après ce n'est pas évident on
serait tenté de lui dire
la faute est qu hier au procès villemin
a dit jean le juge lambert s'était dit
convaincu de l'innocence de la roche
aujourd'hui le commandant de gendarmerie
c'est cela exprime un avis contraire
on comprend pourquoi l'assassinât du
petit grégory reste un mystère dominique
verdeilhan eric de lannion l'honneur
d'un capitaine le 16 octobre 84
il fut l'un des premiers sur les bords
de la vologne aujourd'hui soulagement
soulagement de dire que pour lui il
fallait pour suivre la piste la roche
soulagement aussi de dire ce qu'il pense
du juge lambert de son manque de sérieux
je ne veux pas en rajouter par rapport à
ce qui a été dit hier mais avec lui on
n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au bout alors les
médias ont occupé le vide après le juge
jean michel lambert et lui maurice simon
il a reculé son départ en retraite pour
tenter d'élucider la faire jusqu'à y
laisser sa santé
c'est maître jacques les hôtes et qui
fut un moment avocats dans le dossier
grégory qui lui rend un hommage appuyé
et cornemps au passage le juge jean
michel lambert
je ne comprends pas comment
avec cette évidence des chronomètres et
du temps nécessaire pour mettre un
enfant à l'eau qui a été estimé compte
tenu des rapports des médecins légistes
à 4 à 5 minutes vois pas comment on peut
dire que on croit à la culpabilité d'une
personne comme christine villemin
troisième juge dans le dossier deuxième
juge à la barre jean paul martin il a
refermé le dossier grégory par un
non-lieu pour christine villemin
devant la cour d'assises il fait état
d'éléments qui l'ont poussé à croire que
bernard laroche a enlevé grégory et l'on
relèvera aujourd'hui le sentiment d'un
magistrat exprimés à la barre devant la
cour d'assises
dans un dossier de procédure il n'y a ni
pleurs ni sueur c'est quelque chose
d'assez petit zay et qui peut être un
danger
mince consolation une cour d'assises
offre aujourd'hui à la justice
l'occasion de donner à ce dossier
une vraie dimension à dijon la cour
d'assises de la côte-d'or a ordonné ce
matin une nouvelle expertise détaillée
des poumons prélevés sur le corps du
petit grégory il s'agit d'apporter des
éléments nouveaux sur les conditions de
la mort de l'enfant
aujourd'hui alors que débute la
quatrième semaine d'audience on va se
pencher sur les écrits du corbeau les
avant cela ce matin la cour a entendu le
témoignage de jean jacques leconte qui
était le procureur de la république au
moment des faits dominique verdeilhan
gibrat gries la sphère ne les avaient
pas réunie depuis de nombreuses années
ce matin dans la salle des témoins ils
se sont retrouvés le juge jean michel
lambert à dijon pour la seconde fois
jean jacques leconte à l'époque il était
procureur de la république à epinal
aujourd'hui il est président de chambre
en guadeloupe les avocats de la partie
civile s'inquiète de savoir ce qu'il a
fait pour protéger bernard laroche
mais pouvoir était limité il n'est pas
de notre compétence de servir de garde
du corps
néanmoins par souci d'humanité j'ai
alerté le préfet de région
il m'avait dit avoir fait le nécessaire
voilà le procureur n'a pas d'états d'âme
pas de regrets il se refuse à porter un
jugement sur l'instruction du juge
lambert le procureur se retranche
derrière l'obligation de réserve comme
un leitmotiv le magistrat répond
je fais peut-être preuve de désinvolture
mais je ne me souviens pas à huit jours
d'intervalle les pertes de mémoire
semble être le point commun entre le
procureur le conte et le juge lambert la
énième relance de l'interminable affaire
grégory cette fois ce sont les parents
de l'enfant assassiné qui porte plainte
contre les dysfonctionnements de la
justice christine villemin notamment
dont l'innocence n'avait été reconnu
qu'après huit ans de procédure dominique
verdeilhan alain poirier des auditions
les villemin en ont subi beaucoup depuis
octobre 84 ce jour de joints 94 il était
devant les sénateurs et déjà christine
et jean marie faisait le procès de la
justice vous voudrions dire que les
victimes sont en droit d'attendre de la
justice procureur ou magistrat
instructeur
ce que nous n'avons pas connu le respect
de leur douleur une écoute et réconfort
dix-huit ans après la mort du petit
grégory ses parents attaque l'état et le
juge lambert en personne ils réclament
près de 200000 euros de dédommagement
autopsie incomplet perte de pièces à
conviction annulations de procédure les
avocats des villemin énumère les charges
contre le juge à l'audience cet après
midi pascal le fur le procureur
reconnaît des dysfonctionnements des
malfaçons
mais pour christine et jean-marie la
page n'est pas encore tournée 18 ans se
sont écoulés il essaye de se
reconstruire
ce qui n'est pas évident d'une part
compte tenu du fait qu'un enfant a été
assassiné et d'autre part compte tenu du
calvaire judiciaire que madame villemin
a dû endurer enduré durant deux heures
ce fut d'abord le procès du juge lambert
et pour son avocat c'était avant tout un
procès d'intention vouloir tout ciblé
sur le juge lambert en disant c'est lui
qui est responsable de tout c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument
inacceptable pour lui il ne peut pas
l'accepter
depuis sa mutation 87 il est juge de
l'expropriation à bourg-en-bresse
régulièrement il écrit un livre pour ses
supérieurs directs
il n'y a rien à redire le petit juge a
bonheur
[Musique]